we are set to play ball with boba chat
in the batter's box already with a 2-2
kicks and deals check swing did he go
the last good first and yes he did said
through short water buchet didn't like
the call and tonino gets up and tags him
out and that's the way our ballgame
begins as blake snell records a
strikeout of beau bechet here's biggio
and now the left-hander's still ready to
pitch out of his way swinging in a miss
he struck him out as he challenged him
with a fastball at 95.5 so here's tasker
hernandez one for seven of the series
one two pitch on its way swinging gonna
miss he
struck him out so snell strikes out this
side one on with what out anthony alford
snow from the set the pitch swing and a
miss
he struck him out as alfred goes down
and fourth strikeout rather for blake
was a strikeout in the first inning one
ball and one strike and a fastball to
beau muscled into left field down for a
base hit bargo charges hard but he'll
play it on a long bounce brandon drury
goes to second and the blue jays making
noise with two down again fourth team
fastball right at the top of the zone no
stride two strikes he was able to put it
in play that wasn't the two-strike
approach by any means but he gets that
fastball and singles in the left center
and the hitter will be kevin vigil two
again with two men in scoring possession
and a cut and a miss
he strikes him out to retire the side
leaving
two more men
aboard and now randall grichik lying
into left field a base hit for gritches
and now brandon lau who struck out
against hatch in the first inning
[Applause]
and a fly ball into right center that's
gonna be in there for a base hit laos
gonna stretch it into two and it's in
there safely ahead of the throw cranes
pick up their first hit well you get
that ball deep enough out there into
right center field and you're afforded
that luxury fastball
and it was out over the plate brandon
loud just goes out and swats it out into
right center field and then reading the
outfielders taking a deeper angle he's
going to head into second base two out
opportunity for the race
richard to oscar hernandez and danny
jansen to back the pitch lace to left
field that's down for a base hit tight
near the line a long bounce cut off by
margot richard could turn around first
base thinking about two but marco with
his speed handled that ball on one
bounce he got the throwback in quickly
so he'll check in with a long single all
three times up all three times aboard
for randall grichard tayoska hernandez
and the base hit punch through the left
side for the raids at three men
margot has trouble that ball pops away
from him and now grichik who is going to
advance to third will come all the way
around to score and in the third base
goes hernandez to what started out as a
base hit got out there between kirby and
margot and got away in the outfield
grichik scores and it's one nothing
toronto starting with the pitch out over
the heart of the plate oscar hernandez
able to hammer it right through the
infield and you had all three remember
he had all three infielders over there
so he's able to get it through them and
then get it deep enough off the glove of
margaux a run scores he gets all the way
to third base just a bad series of
events there for the raise
now a little looper on the first pitch
to jansen and that's going to get
hernandez home from third and it's just
like that a two-nothing ball game
two-nothing lead with boba shett trying
to deliver a late knockout blow zach's
are packed the o2
swinging a hard ground ball base hit
into left field jansen is in to score
rounding third here comes brandon jury
the throw to the plate is offline up to
the first base side two runs driven in
from bo buchet and it's four nothing
blue jays here in the sixth inning and
the blue jays continue to pour it on
still nobody out in this sixth inning as
the hit parade continues well what an
inning for the blue jays one right after
another each hitter having a better at
bat than the last
and bobas shed an o2 breaking ball
ketchup leaves it on the inside part of
the plate and he hooks it into left
field to drive home two more runs
six consecutive hits to start the inning
as we move to the bottom of the sixth
inning and again g-man choi comes up
hitting right-handed and this time he
smokes one left center and gone we told
you he had just been messing around
hitting right-handed
and hit righty for the first time as a
big leaguer a couple of innings ago
against k and struck out and now he hits
a home run
tampa bay might be the most aggressive
team as far as doing
unconventional things and they have
allowed g manchuy to hit right hand and
he comes up with a home run give me over
fastball in the first pitch and he
smokes he did this during summer camp
where he hit against his teammates
because there were so many left-handers
in a row for the pitchers he said i want
to hit right-handed to give pitchers a
different look
ground ball that's a fair ball by the
bag up the left field line margot is
going to get two on this one to lead it
off in the bottom of the seventh inning
margot is able to capitalize with a
leadoff double here in december
meanwhile the tying run is coming to the
plate right now and here's the guy you
were talking about yoshitsutsugo
[Applause]
the only place to first the runs gonna
score
adamus moves up to second that makes it
a four to two ball game the bases are
loaded
you could see that something's bothering
him that would obviously speak to the
severe lack of command that he has shown
the last few hitters
and he was definitely trying to pitch
through something so the blue jays will
go to the bullpen a one-run deficit with
brandon lau coming up
and the ground ball to the right side
who's gonna come first he is safe at
first and this game is tied
the rays get a thomas across the plane
two one
down the middle strike three called
runner breaks towards third base and
espional is thrown out tries to get
elusive here
tries to sneak in that right ooh
he's safe
if he didn't come off the bag he's safe
that right hand got into the corner of
the bag right
here that other shot that we just had
shows it perfectly did he scrape the
thumb on the way by we'll see
yeah
and a fly ball not overly deep
since sugo is there he's gonna make the
catch a tag espinal comes to the plate
and he is safe so here's kiermeier
and it shot up the right side back into
the corner
here comes smith to tie it martinez
hitting third lenars will wave him home
rays are gonna win
safe at the plate and the raids scored
two in the tenth on the shot up the
right side by caremeyer it's a 6-5 final